hey listen guys you don't want to do a
gallbladder flush
if you potentially have gall stones okay
I'm gonna tell you why a long time ago I
was really into colon cleanses and
flushing out my gallbladder I was living
in an in San Diego I had a practice and
I decided to do a gallbladder cleanse so
I proceeded to drink 12 ounces of olive
oil with about two ounces of Epsom salts
okay I was gonna drink all that but
before I drank it I took a handful of
beet tablets concentrated B tablets
right it's gonna purge and get rid of
all my golf stones and my toxins so I
took the beet pills and I flushed it
down with this oil you know I think it
was like 16 out and might have been 16
ounces of olive oil and epsom salts it
was delicious so I got it down and then
I laid on my right side okay for like a
half-hour first of all my gallbladder
was just kind of going crazy it was like
purging and it was dumping and
unfortunately the beet tablets because I
took them all together
got stuck in my throat and they started
to you know be a solid mass in my throat
in my esophagus to the point where I
couldn't even breathe okay obstructed my
breathing I actually almost died it was
like it just suffocated me anyway to
make a long story short I didn't die I'm
still here and I was able to get through
that but what was interesting about this
gallbladder flush was I had this idea
that I was going to purge my gall stones
okay and you know you look in the toilet
and you see these green little balls
okay and you might if you're not
understanding what they are you might
say oh those are the stones they're
floating no they're not the stones
they're not the golf stones these are
just little balls of bile the green okay
so basically what you do when you do a
gallbladder flushes you purge your bile
now gall stones are caused
by a bio deficiency okay so if you
proceed to flush the the bile that you
have left out of the gallbladder and out
of the liver and because a lot of the
bile is recycled like 90% of your bile
is recycled and you're already deficient
now you're gonna end up with hardly any
bile so without bile
your risk for getting stones goes way
way up and it could take a long time to
get that back
bile is like the detergent that helps
you dissolve fats in grease it helps you
extract fought side by vitamins from the
food that you eat the omega-3 fatty
acids that are really beneficial for
vision for heart for brain function
cognition mood etc so golf stones
consist of a concentrated cholesterol
and calcium deposit simply because you
don't have enough file to keep them
dissolved so the last thing you want to
do is a gallbladder flush okay I will
show you what to do but you don't want
to do this because basically you get rid
of the bile that you need to help
dissolve the stones so before we get
into what to do to dissolve stones let's
just talk about what causes stones the
number one thing is high levels of
insulin okay that comes from eating a
lot of carbs and sugar so that's number
one number two is estrogen and this is
why women when they're pregnant have a
higher risk of eating stones because the
spike of estrogen could be women that
are on hormone replacement therapy birth
control pills and also increase stress
because it activates cortisol so high
levels of cortisol will also increase
golf stones insulin okay so this idea
that just eating a lot of saturated fats
cause gall stones is a myth if the
combination of the high level of fat
with the high level of carbohydrate okay
it's a combination of those two but to
trigger the bio release you need
saturated fat and protein both of those
increase bile production so if you're in
a very very low
protein low saturated fat diet that
could be one reason why you have stones
in the first place okay
so what are some things you can do to
help yourself if you have a gall bladder
problem or you have stones the first
thing is intermittent fasting okay
because that's gonna first of all reduce
insulin and it's going to give your
digestive system a chance to heal and
clear out all the food and not work so
hard so that's first thing number two
don't do a low-fat diet do in a Catholic
keto diet which is moderate protein a
little higher fat because we need some
of it but we also need a lot of
vegetables too okay the vegetables will
feed the microbes that you need to help
recycle the bile and also the vegetables
will help the liver function better as
well since the liver produces bile in
the first place bile salts would be a
very good idea to take me since bile
salts you can get them in a purified
form to help you dissolve the stones so
I put a link down below for more
information on that topic and also apple
cider vinegar will increase the flow of
digestive juices and bile through the
liver as well as phenol will also help
as well and one less a really cool
technique I'm going to put a link down
for a video that I did a long time ago
and it's actually like a manual massage
to the digestive organs and so you can
check that out that can actually take
out a lot of tension and spasm that's
developed from years of eating poorly
alright see you next time so if you want
more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis how about that